hello and welcome to this video playing
I am Kali man column on him
so let's transpose a joke this is silly
[Music]
see what he does and we actually a place
you form a freeman to remember it don't
play this all that often I don't think I
could be for him maybe can play d5 hmm I
was too early I won't move too early
that's a bit too quickly play okay I'm
not sure if it really has all that great
if equals D 5 K cos B 5 let's see the
other standard break in this position
that's unfortunate
mm-hmm okay and it's always it's
annoying because just a normal position
and I just play Queen d2 first and
nothing happens like that
and now I have to somehow yeah already
solve problems okay we teach at 95 so
here here I was thinking a tape or take
therefore I take there first and then
Bishop f3 that was my idea
okay I mean it was all not intended bad
move water now I know if I think that's
with check so that doesn't help yeah I
just try to play with my pieces hope I
could get some getting some decent
pressure here against the pond yeah
maybe 90 force no not now okay um so
takes cheeks what's the problem I mean
I'm in a pin but still
yeah I mean I can hardly not take I mean
so take here our Queen d7 is actually a
move that's stupid
now I can take Pete no I cannot take the
sex I can take p6 okay so we have to go
to c7 basically almost okay now I can at
least capture on v6 Queen h5 leads
nowhere
I can also do this that's cleared
maybe we should be six simply one-time
interesting but I have to ship to c6
where are you going
Ruby 6a a miracle moose yeah that's
funny
okay
not very convenient for my rent I will
tell win the pawn and a six week might
so be drawn it I have so he wants to and
then he wants to take a three because of
the background [ __ ] that's true
nice probably going to be a draw anyway
no I'm playing for K go to this ending
Highmore a that is not not sure how
clear draw this is probably it is a
vertically clear draw over to be point
is quite outside
put this on p6
play Bishop g8 and h6 and now it should
probably be wrong I also have the wrong
Bishop here with the very have an H Paul
at the end yeah that's problem never
enough for anything start a clear draw
it goes to g3 then okay it is a clear
draw draw comfort game drawn huh that's
a bit disappointing at the end I mean
okay I'm happier that I didn't just lose
after this opening where I screwed up
the move water is this yeah yeah this is
just not a good idea I mean I can just
apply this normal move and then play
before and so on
just cover this it was a superficially
weak move yeah it's okay the engine
seems to still think that this is kind
of playable yeah and I take looks better
at what I also saw
now Kayla I was home not intended to
okay here look chicks stronger okay
okay I like some sense you take with the
roots like we need to next something
like that this is just wrong it's very
drawing group d1 plus more interesting
yeah but it takes
what's the DL g3 ads actually the same
ending man this is probably just a drone
okay guys thanks for watching